the item that we're gonna be looking at
today is SCP 76 this is an email from
director Maria Jones record-keeping and
information Security Administration
subject revision of SCP 76 is SCP 5
I have to go on record as saying that I
seriously object to the proposed
revisions of the SCP 76 containment
procedures file I know that redact all
important stuff already claims it's a
security risk but you and I both know
it's just top brass trying to sweep
their biggest and most embarrassing
mistake ever under the damn rock Omega 7
happened it existed those people died
because you screwed up
and you can't change that no matter how
hard you try to hide it for God's sake
man those people guarding him deserve to
know what exactly he is and what he did
what we did how we [ __ ] up so they
know better object class Keter special
containment procedures containment area
25 B is to be located 200 metres below
sea level tunneled out of solid bedrock
and a seismological e stable area sole
access to the containment facility is to
be through a vertical elevator shaft
separated every 50 meters with a
reinforced blast door constructed of 20
centimeters thick material shielding
elevator shafts shall be flooded with
seawater but not in use containment area
25 B is to be constructed with the
following components an outer security
perimeter against outside threats
staffed by security personnel trained in
close quarters battle and counter
intrusion tactics an administrative and
support area consisting of support
facilities and living quarters for
on-site personnel a primary containment
zone consisting of a seven meter cube in
case of 1.5 meters of reinforced
material primary containment zone is
designed to be flooded and drained as
needed and should remain filled with
seawater unless access to contents is
required a 150 meter killing corridor
which is to be the sole access to the
primary containment zone from the
administer of support area
including water power drainage and
ventilation lines the walls and floor of
the corridor to be reinforced in a
similar manner to the primary
containment so with the addition of an
electric deterrence system capable of
delivering a 20,000 volt shock
a security station located at the
entrance to the killing card or is to be
staffed with no fewer than three armed
security personnel on watch at any one
point in time armament is to include but
not limited to at least one CI W system
on a pintle mount with a clear
line-of-sight
down the corridor the plexiglass screen
to protect the operator from throwing
weapons in the event of a full breach
all on-site staff are to proceed
immediately to the closest security
station for weapons and armor
distribution staff will remain at alert
condition 1 until a CP 76 - 2 is
confirmed neutralized should 90 minutes
pass after declaration of full breach
without a stand-down order being given
by level 4 or higher personnel final
contingency measures will be activated
flooding the entire facility in seawater
and sealing off the access shaft for a
minimum of 24 hours before retrieval is
attempted this will by necessity result
in the deaths of all on-site staff
description SCP 76 consists of two
components a stone cube SCP 76 - one and
a humanoid entity contained within a CP
76 - 2 SCP 76 - one is a 3 meter cube
made of black speckled metamorphic snoke
SCP 76 - 1 are covered in deeply
engraved patterns corresponding to no
known civilizations radioisotope
analysis indicates that the object is
approximately 10,000 years old a door is
located on one side sealed with a lock
0.5 metres in width
surrounded by 20 smaller locks in a
circular pattern has a viet none of the
keys have been sound-making the door and
possible to lock once closed interior
temperature is approximately 93 degrees
Kelvin and cannot be altered by any
means internal or external directly in
the centre of the room is a 2.1 3 metre
tall stone coffin held in place and
sealed shut by several chains of unknown
make and substance which are attached to
the inner corners of a CP 76 - 1 SCP 76
- 2 resembles a lean semitic human male
in his late 20s
his hair is black and eyes are gray skin
tone olive subject is 1.96 meters in
height and 81 point 65 kilograms in
weight numerous tattoos depicting arcane
and occult iconography are present all
over the body mostly in the form of
leering demonic faces and ranges from
subtle to openly ostentatious subject
when encased inside of SCP 76 - one is
technically dead however occasionally
SCP 76 - - will awaken effectively
reanimate complete with all vital
processes needed to sustain a living
human being
subject will then attempt to leave a CP
70 6-1
if successful subject will enter a
trance state and seek out the nearest
human being ignoring all other living
things in the process upon coming into
contact with living humans a CP 70 6-2
will enter a rage state in which it
attempts to engage and kill all human
beings encounter today only the subjects
death has been shown to be effective and
ending these rampages terminating SCP 76
- - is often problematic due to its
significant physical abilities subject
has superhuman strength and speed and
although not invulnerable has shown a
remarkable ability to ignore pain and
shock pressing on this Bible would be
debilitating wounds to normal humans
prior encounters have shown that SCP 76
- - has the ability to among other
things rip through a reinforced steel
security door over the course of four
minutes of sustained assault clear over
64 meters of distance in under three
seconds
take multiple 50 caliber BMG rounds to
the head and survive for several minutes
to continue killing despite severe
damage to the cerebellum SWAT handgun
and assault rifle caliber bullets out of
the air with a length of steel rebar
survived for over one hour deprived of
oxygen before finally as fixating a CB
76 - twos most unusual ability however
is its ability to apparently materialize
bladed weapons out of nowhere
slow-motion footage reveals that the
blades in question are actually pulled
from a miniature dimensional rift
described as a small hole in space
where this portal leads is unknown as is
how SCP 70 6-2 is capable of generating
set rifts footage of the blades in
question shows them to be made out of a
completely non reflective black material
appearing as a black void in space as
the blades rapidly vanish after leaving
the subjects possession no structural
analysis is possible this time SCP 76 -
- has effectively been killed several
times in various matters sustained fire
from multiple heavy caliber machine guns
asphyxiation crushed beneath a 13.6
metric ton piece of elevator equipment
for use on SCP 76 - one cremation
through the use of a thermite th-three
grenade placed directly inside SCP 76
open chest cabin during the worst breach
to date containment area 25 which
previously housed SCP 76 was forced to
detonate its on-site warhead as a last
attempt to contain SCP 76 - - while it
was attempting escape resulting total
destruction of the site and all on-site
personnel
is CP 76 - one survived upon death as CP
76 - 2 s remains will putrified rapidly
until reduced to dust as CP 76 - 1 and
the coffin within will then slam shut
with great force and the lock will
rotate sealing it shut as CP 76 - 2 will
then reform within the comp a process
taking anywhere from 6 hours
to 25 years what posthumous analysis of
SCP 76 - 2 exists shows that it has an
internal system highly different from
our own documented in additional CP 76
was found in Mongolia and 18th by
archaeologists from England all members
of the expedition were subsequently
killed on the return voyage home s CB 76
was recovered from the ship by the
Society one of the organisations that
later emerged into the modern global
occult coalition placed on display in
their inner sanctum
SCP 76 remained in storage for years
until a-c-p 76 - 2 became active and
escaped on the reason for SCP 76 is
activation is currently unknown
but it was at this point that the keys
to the outer shell were lost a massive
manhunt lasting over three years took
place until a-c-p 70 6-2 was
incapacitated killing it and causing it
to reform inside SCP 76 - won by then
retrieved and secured by agents of the
SCP foundation subject was in custody
for three or more years under constant
supervision and was terminated whenever
it became active although it was
occasionally able to escape for short
periods of time often due to security
breaches caused by attacks from other
organizations the Foundation's death
toll due to this was after the last
incident the current procedures
regarding SCP 76 were implemented
although they are upgraded regularly
with the increase in technological
standards yeah count yourself lucky
you've never met this guy take it from
me